[Música]
subió la cifra de víctimas fatales que
dejó el atentado a las afueras del
aeropuerto de kabul capital de
afganistán y podría pasar los 170
muertos todavía no se ha determinado una
cita exacta y un pentágono aseguró que
no fueron dos sino una explosión que la
que tuvo lugar este jueves en el ataque
reivindicado por el autodenominado de
estado islámico
este viernes al 24 dedica buena parte de
su programación a la situación de las
mujeres en afganistán sus conquistas
durante las dos últimas décadas y sus
derechos no se podrían perder ahora que
infor talibán retomó las riendas del
país
con el 73 votos a favor y 50 en contra
legislativo peruano le otorgó el voto de
confianza al gabinete del presidente
pedro castillo y al primer ministro
guido bellido castillo cerebro el apoyo
del parlamento y llamó al diálogo entre
los diferentes sectores políticos
seguimos con información de américa
latina y el mundo aquí en tras 24 mi
nombre es liliana valencia iniciamos en
afganistán donde el pentágono acaba de
anunciar que ejecutó un ataque con
drones contra un planificador del estado
islámico este ataque se produce en
represalia del atentado que perpetró
justamente el autodenominado de estado
islámico este jueves y que aceleró la
salida de varios países occidentales la
cifra de víctimas del ataque subió en
las últimas horas y los fallecidos
estarían entre los 100 y los 170 según
agencias internacionales y fuentes
afganas respectivamente para clara calle
nos cuenta más
comenzaron los funerales para despedir a
las decenas de personas que murieron el
jueves tras el ataque del estado
islámico en afganistán cerca del
aeropuerto de kabul pero no todos han
podido hacer el ritual decenas de
cadáveres estaban en el suelo a las
afueras del hospital wazir akbar khan de
la capital la morgue del centro clínico
no da abasto y muchos familiares apenas
están viajando desde provincias lejanas
otros no pudieron recuperar los cuerpos
a tiempo a pesar de estar en kabul
no había nadie para sacar a los heridos
y a los cadáveres del agua y la mayoría
de las personas murieron porque los
extranjeros bloquearon la carretera
durante una hora después del ataque
algunos murieron porque las carreteras
estaban bloqueadas a sandra más aunque
el pentã gono advierte que las amenazas
siguen activas cientos de afganos
siguieron dirigiéndose a la terminal el
grupo talibán tomó el control en la zona
y bloqueó el acceso al puente aéreo
vivimos aquí porque teníamos un vuelo
pero han bloqueado las carreteras y no
permiten a nadie entrar al aeropuerto ni
siquiera a quienes han trabajado en
instituciones extranjeras ni a los
periodistas ni a quienes corren peligro
así que la gente está en una situación
muy difícil
al menos 5000 afganos siguen dentro del
aeropuerto esperando que los saquen del
país antes de que las tropas extranjeras
se terminan de retirar el 31 de agosto y
a pesar de que el talibán intenta calmar
los ánimos diciendo que luego podrán
salir en vuelos comerciales todavía no
es claro qué aerolíneas regresarían a un
aeropuerto controlado por los militantes
fundamentalistas el grupo le pidió a
turquía que opere el aeropuerto pero el
presidente reyerta yverdon respondió que
tomara una decisión sólo después de que
la nueva administración afgana sea clara
mujeres influyentes de diferentes
esferas se han pronunciado por la
preocupante situación de las niñas y
mujeres en afganistán desde figuras
políticas hasta personajes del mundo del
entretenimiento y la cultura han alzado
su voz y esto es lo que han dicho hasta
ahora
estoy profundamente preocupada por la
situación en afganistán en este momento
especialmente por la seguridad de las
mujeres y las niñas allí tuve la
oportunidad de hablar con algunas
activistas de afganistán incluidas las
activistas de derechos de las mujeres y
ellas comparten su preocupación de no
estar seguras de cómo van a ser sus
vidas indíbil like world to be cristian
mencionado afganistán en sus redes
queríamos permitir que la mayor cantidad
posible de personas en afganistán
llevaran una vida libre buena y con
autodeterminación las niñas sobre todo
las mujeres que ahora han asistido a la
escuela durante 20 años
vargas su único lumen o fundamento regla
una línea roja fundamental será el trato
de los talibanes a las mujeres y las
niñas y el respeto de sus derechos a la
libertad la libertad de movimiento la
educación la libre expresión y el empleo
uy les imploramos permitan que las
personas se vayan de manera segura y
demuestren que ustedes van a ser una
administración que tiene en cuenta el
bienestar de las mujeres y las niñas y
la capacidad de ser educadores y todas
esas cosas a las que la comunidad
internacional viene pidiendo desde hace
algún tiempo porque el mundo entero
estará mirando
es realmente difícil para mí hablar de
eso y es desgarrador lo que está
sucediendo en este mundo y lo siento
pero realmente me rompe el corazón
qué es
lo siento pero afganistán irán ya sabes
todos esos países donde la gente no
puede salir libremente y no entiendo la
razón y por supuesto soy una mujer y
esto es muy muy difícil de ver lo que
está sucediendo ahí con las mujeres
si what's happening there for women
antes de cambiar de tema les confirmamos
que eeuu dice a sus ciudadanos que
abandonen inmediatamente las puertas del
aeropuerto de kabul esa es una
información en desarrollo continuamos
con más noticias porque el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón se encuentra en
irak donde desarrolla su segunda visita
oficial desde que llegó al cargo el
objetivo del viaje que se extenderá
hasta el domingo es promover la
estabilidad en la región pero a la
cumbre de este sábado en la capital
iraquí con la cual la nación a vitoria
espera posicionarse como mediadora en
los conflictos regionales y apaciguar
las tensiones macro visitará las
ciudades de y también con el primer
ministro mustafá alcaide
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
el primer ministro israelí naftalí
bennett se encontraron por primera vez
en washington para buscar puntos en
común sobre el acuerdo nuclear de 2005
que quedó en vilo desde que el ex
presidente del al trono retiró a su país
después de un retraso de un día debido
al ataque en el aeropuerto de kabul en
by derive net se reunieron para
restablecer el torno de las relaciones
bilaterales
baden afirmó que ambos estaban
discutiendo la amenaza de irán y su
compromiso es evitar el desarrollo de
armas nucleares
sabes estos mismos días ilustran cómo
sería el mundo
si un régimen radical adquiriera un arma
nuclear ese matrimonio sería una
pesadilla nuclear para el mundo entero
irán es el principal exportador mundial
de terror inestabilidad y violaciones a
los derechos humanos y mientras estamos
aquí sentados
los iraníes están haciendo girar sus
centrifugadoras en natanz y ford y
tenemos que detenerlos
wigan hasta fer vamos américa latina
donde la controvertida política
migratoria llamada quédate en mexico es
problemática para miles de migrantes en
la frontera una medida que había sido
aprobada por el expresidente donald
trump abolida por el actual presidente
joe biden y que la corte suprema con una
mayoría conservadora acaba de
reinstaurar una pelea política
estadounidense con la cual méxico no
quiere tener que lidiar
en méxico la política establecida a
portugal trump durante su mandato y que
obliga a los migrantes a quedarse en
méxico mientras se esperan la aprobación
de su solicitud de asilo fue retomado
este martes un anuncio hecho por la
corte suprema liderada en mayoría por
los conservadores el presidente yo
baiden había abolido al inicio de su
mandato esta política pero no pudo parar
el poder judicial mientras tanto en los
refugios sobre poblados de inmigrantes
en la frontera con eeuu como en reynosa
el regreso de esta política empeoró una
situación ya complicada
para los entonces qué vamos a hacer
ahora me dijo que si no hay una ayuda de
aquí de este mal lado está mal yo me voy
pero no me regreso porque yo mero que
aquí estoy como un perro votado esta
decisión judicial parece no obligar a
méxico a cambiar su posición como lo
anunció el ministro de asuntos
exteriores roberto velasco álvarez el
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador declaró que a pesar de la nueva
política continuarán brindando ayuda y
seguro a los migrantes presentes en su
frontera pero reiteró su propuesta de
invertir en américa central para parar
el flujo migratorio sin embargo esto no
puede ser
eterno
tenemos que ir al fondo
y eso significa
invertir para el desarrollo
de los pueblos pobres méxico es la
última parada para miles de inmigrantes
americanos pero también asiáticos y
africanos que anhelan llegar a eeuu y
canadá
con 73 votos a favor y 50 en contra el
congreso de perú otorgó este viernes su
voto de confianza al gabinete
ministerial elegido por el presidente
pedro castillo tras un debate de dos
sesiones el primer ministro peruano guío
bellido y sus ministros habían sido
cuestionados por varios sectores
políticos por su apoyo a grupos de
izquierda y el supuesto apoyo de ha
vencido a un ex integrante del grupo
guerrillero sendero luminoso de esta
manera se elimina por ahora el temor de
una nueva crisis política en el país
andino informe han de amaya
el congreso peruano le dio su voto de
confianza al gabinete ministerial del
presidente pedro castillo han votado a
favor de la cuestión de confiar hasta 73
congresistas en contra 50 abstenciones 0
en consecuencia ha sido aprobada la
cuestión de confianza planteada por el
señor y david ugarte presidente del
consejo de ministros la votación que
llegó luego de dos sesiones de debates
en el congreso se produjo por la poca
simpatía que algunos miembros del
gobierno tienen por el gabinete de guido
bellido presidente del consejo de
ministros
bellido es además investigado por una
supuesta apología del terrorismo en
mensajes que publicó en su cuenta en
facebook apoyando a un ex miembro del
grupo sendero luminoso minutos después
del voto el presidente peruano reacciona
en twitter es momento de incentivar un
profundo diálogo entre todas las raíces
políticas sobre todo con los sectores
más olvidados de nuestra sociedad
construyamos juntos un perú más justo en
total respeto de todas sus culturas y
sin discriminación entre sus ciudadanos
el jueves el debate en el congreso
despertó reacciones en las calles de
lima a favor y en contra de la votación
los detractores del gobierno de pedro
castillo quien lleva apenas un mes en el
poder argumentan además que sus
representantes son los responsables del
alza de los precios y las dificultades
económicas de los peruanos
el resultado de la votación de este
viernes desactiva una crisis de gabinete
y una ausencia de diálogo entre los
poderes del estado que marcaron la
legislatura anterior con la disolución
del congreso y la caída de tres
presidentes
en las últimas sobre la tormenta ida se
convirtió en huracán de categoría 1 y
avanza por el caribe y ella tocó tierra
en cuba dos veces y se siente con
fuertes lluvias y vientos en gran parte
del territorio nacional
huracán presenta a vientos máximos
sostenidos de más de 120 kilómetros por
hora y se dirige hacia la costa sur de
eeuu a donde llegaría este fin de semana
como categoría 4 según las previsiones
una nueva en nuevos lean las autoridades
hicieron un llamado a la población para
que evacúe aquellas zonas fuera del
alcance del sistema delitos
por primera vez después de 53 años miles
de pequeñas y medianas empresas podrían
incorporarse legalmente a la economía en
cuba aunque los empresarios reciben con
felicidad este momento histórico hay
opiniones encontradas pues consideran
que se necesitará mucho más que esto
para activar una economía de este país
que lleva décadas bajo el control
exclusivo del estado y que además fue
fuertemente golpeada por las medidas
para contener la pandemia de kobe 19
la espera terminó por fin los
empresarios de las pequeñas y medianas
empresas se preparan para una economía
más abierta después de la autorización
del decreto de ley que autoriza el
funcionamiento de pymes privadas y
estatales en cuba desde tiendas de
comida hasta talleres de reparación de
bicicletas celebran la decisión es un
buen momento que estábamos esperando
hace muchísimo tiempo que realmente
pudiéramos en el sector no estatal en
este caso el sector privado podernos
incluir como parte verdaderamente común
análisis global de la economía de país
es un momento histórico en la economía
del país socialista pues desde 1968 es
la primera vez que los dueños de
empresas privadas podrán abrir las
puertas de sus negocios sin que ésta sea
considerada una actividad ilegal hubiera
sido muy provechoso
es que saliera antes pero si salió ahora
ahora esconde que aprovechar
sin embargo hay algunos que consideran
que este método de reactivación no será
suficiente para sacar al país de la
crisis económica en donde el gobierno
cubano culpa a eeuu por sus constantes
sanciones además dicha crisis económica
habría sido una de las principales
razones del estallido social de
protestas en junio no estoy muy de
acuerdo que se me siga hablando la
palabra gradualidad desde 2016 se está
hablando de la pequeña y mediana empresa
y todavía hoy me están hablando de
gradualidad cuando el país lo que
necesita es rapidez no gradualidad los
empresarios podrán importar exportar
fijar precios y atraer inversión
extranjera aunque sólo podrán tener un
máximo de 100 empleados y ser
propietarios de una única empresa
realizamos con imágenes que nos llegan
desde australia donde un granjero logró
formar con con sus cientos de ovejas un
corazón en forma un corazón gigante en
los campos el truco lo logró poniéndole
comida manualmente y formando justamente
un corazón con el objetivo de rendir
homenaje a un tío suyo que falleció la
imagen grabada desde el cielo se ha
hecho viral en las redes sociales así
final
así que analizamos contenido ustedes con
más entradas 24 punto com
[Música]